I'm Jake Foley
I'm 57.
I'm again
life's just a game right
it's all in how you read and
your opponents
Sam tell you what's going on only that
is big Stakes
[Music]
there needs to be a catalyst
and I don't have time to wait around for
these guys to tell me the truth
cheese let's
25 million on the table who are these
guys it's Pokemon and I want to play
forgive my cynicism but wants to catch
I just thought without the stakes
tonight
race 175.
follow him Jake goes all in
surprise Alex
I poisoned you no that's not funny
I did ask a lot of questions I never got
any satisfactory answers I'm all right
with death I'm not I can't die
this is another one of your surprises
Jake I don't know where we are let's go
okay we got the guys nobody's home check
around they're hiding somewhere
I know you're
Jake
Dad what's she doing hello
there's six of us and three of them we
can take them
life's just a game right now
maximize your voice
minimize your losses
and stay in the game as long as you can
[Music]